welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the mega fan of
HBO that's gonna put you in the HP no
yet these catchphrases are terrible
Westworld season 3 is back with its
second entry and throughout this video
we're going to be recapping the plot
discussing our theories on what's going
on and giving our thoughts on where the
season could be going in the future
we'll also be discussing the cooler old
Jurassic Park and Game of Thrones Easter
eggs that pop up in the entry so if you
miss them and this is the video for you
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
show yet and don't want anything ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel as we will be breaking down the
entire season and please drop a thumbs
up if you enjoy the video without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into a breakdown Westworld
season 3 episode 2 ok so if you didn't
stick around for last week's post-credit
scene and judging by the 50% drop off of
audiences you probably didn't then you
might not have any idea what's going on
in this episode last time we picked up
with mave who had woken up in an Italian
villa in the middle of war world we're
gonna be calling it best world in this
episode that is about it but I'm not
mentioning that again and this 1940's
setting completely juxtaposed the
futuristic town of the first episode in
war world she's joined by hectare
however whilst Maeve wants to escape
from the park we soon realized that
Hector is just playing a part in a loop
and he's just trying to save Mae from
the German forces Maeve was killed and
captured at the end of season 2 and
she's clearly been reprogrammed and put
back into a new loop we'll get into
what's really going on in just a bit but
within this storyline she's going under
the name Isabella we later learn that
this is just a test for fidelity to see
if she can break out for a simulation
and get to the root of what's really
going on it's a really mind-boggling
episode and there's a ton of twists and
turns so I'll try and keep it as
simplistic as possible going forward as
there are a lot of things you can get
lost in the company behind the
simulation insight also wish to get to
the bottom of who was behind the hosts
outbreak and thus they posed to her
several scenarios which will unearth
this though it initially seems like
she's lost the admin powers that she
gained in season 1
she likely still has them in Westworld
it's just that she isn't an admin in the
new shell program it's like being a
website developer and having admin
access to one site you can edit all of
that however if you try to edit another
one your powers have been stripped away
and therefore you can't do it now one of
the big giveaways that this is faked
later on is because these scenes are
shot in a letterbox format so they have
black bars on the top and bottom this
was apparent in season 2 when things
were fake where is the real scenes fully
Philly TV
the world itself is actually based on
the Republic of salò which was a puppet
government set up by German forces
between 1943 to 1945 this was led by
Mussolini who was the leader of the
state however the town was pretty much
just controlled by the Germans I
absolutely loved this introduction and
seeing the Casablanca s go burning
really gets you back on board with the
character what I'm really enjoying about
this season is that it's completely
reinventing our expectations of
Westworld with there being two
completely new aesthetics may even
Hector go on the run chased by the
German forces and they get an awesome
stylish car that helps them race towards
an airstrip upon arriving at a plane
they realize that Germans have killed
the pilot and they're ambushed by
soldiers Maeve is completely torn up by
watching her love die and after coming
to the conclusion that they're both back
to square one she shoots herself in the
head now this could symbolize that she's
completely demoralized and wishes to
just go back to living as a host or it
could show that she wishes to be
transported to the lab which is where we
pick up with her after the credits now
if you haven't seen our breakdown of the
owning titles then make sure you check
it out after this because we go into all
of the hidden meanings that you get from
the graphics anyway from here we jump to
the South China Sea and join Bernard who
is hitched a ride back to West world in
order to track her down
he returns to the church which has an
entranceway to the labs and on his way
he runs into a big character which I'll
get into in just a bit now firstly with
Bernards journey I've got a lot of vibes
of the opening of Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom with there being big gates
bordering the park around the sea this
was a cool little moment in the
introduction of that movie and it isn't
the only Jurassic Park Easter egg either
as later in the episode we see two texts
talking they are played by none other
than DB wise and David Ben
aka the showrunners of HBO's Game of
Thrones if you were wondering what they
got up to after no showing the comic-con
panel and also getting fired from Star
Wars then yeah we now know where they
are we found them I wish Stubbs had just
shut them anyway it turns out they're
discussing selling none other than
drogon from their show to a buyer that
is creating a start-up in Costa Rica
easily Nublar is actually just off the
coast of Costa Rica and nolan and lisa
joy confirmed to IGN at the park is
selling it to indian who run jurassic
park in case you don't know michael
crichton the creator of west world also
created Jurassic Park so there's a nice
little tying together of his two big eye
piece drogon appearing is of course a
nod to Benioff and DB wise but what
makes it even better is that george RR
martin did actually suggest that nolan
and lisa joy create a park called
Westeros world while having dinner with
the pair though this doesn't pop up as
the name it's nice to know that there
have been talks about bringing the
properties under one roof drogon itself
is actually part of medieval world and
fans of the original film franchise may
recognize this as it was a big location
during the films that took place in it
they even have a lute player dropping
the same theme as the west-world tune so
yeah there's lots of Easter eggs packed
into these scenes but now it travels
back to the house in which Ford used to
carry out let's say his darker
experiments and he comes across as
copies as well as Stubbs who's shot
himself we discover that Stubbs's job
was to protect the other hosts he didn't
have a tragic backstory or anything to
tie him to reality and when everything
was over ford programmed him to shoot
himself it didn't completely work as
he's a machine
and nurse Bernard is able to repair him
the to talk about how Dolores brought
Bernard back in order to be his opposite
the yin to his yang that will provide a
counterbalance to her actions and stop
her from going too far it's a nice
psychological look at Dolores who as we
know has lost those around her in the
past due to her bloodlust Maeve is the
wild card that if he secures will
provide him with enough stopping power
to take Dolores down should it ever come
to it Stubbs has regained purpose and he
journeys with Bernard to discover what's
going on Mae wakes up with Lutz
operating her
something is going on because he doesn't
seem to be fully aware of who she is in
season one and two they went through a
lot in Sylvester also makes an
appearance unaware of their shared
history we learn that they are hosts
themselves and all part of a completely
new simulation may have grabs a drill to
give herself a lobotomy but she stopped
by Lea Sizemore who we learn apparently
managed to survive the massacre last
time now why may be so quick to believe
him is because she's seen firsthand that
medical equipment has advanced to the
point that it can save people as long as
they aren't shot in their vital organs
so though Sizemore was shot more times
than 50 cent and could probably release
his own rap album called yes ladies
Sizemore does matter the character is
likely dead
Mabry enters war world to meet up with
them however she realizes that he's fake
and that she's just inside a simulation
carried out by insight this has been
trying to mimic Delos and it copied the
staff labs and location in order to
construct a false reality that would
track air however it didn't know the
thoughts and connections that Dolores
had and therefore it's illusion was not
perfect she breaks the simulation by
asking one of the hosts what the square
root of negative 1 is and this shuts the
Machine down and allows her to wreak
havoc the processing power is unable to
deal with a lot of things and in trying
to solve the equation it has to buffer
certain things like gravity and complex
operations
it's brilliant watching the almost
matrix like special effects as she tears
through the labs in town Westworld has
always had brilliant special effects but
this is breathtaking at some points now
one of the most interesting aspects of
the entire thing is that Sizemore states
that everything feels real clearly it
was enough to fool Maeve too and it does
play into the theory that everything
we've seen so far could be a simulation
within a simulation this was given lip
service in episode 1 and it's slowly a
theory that is picking up a lot of steam
I do you think that it's one big red
herring but perhaps the entire show is
just something ran by humans before
creating AI to discover whether there's
a scenario in which machines would rise
up against humanity there's a lot of
talk of Oracle's and prophecies in the
series and it is possible that this is
something that could be going on the
simulation within a simulation thing is
a bit
much I do think it would rob the show of
a lot of it's more important moments by
relegating them to being fake but it is
definitely a possibility and like what's
going on the screen is also full screen
so going by the rules of the show we can
guess that it's real back in West world
will see Bernard and Stubbs discover
Maeve and we learned that a brain was
removed which is how she was able to be
shifted into a new machine
Bernard scans his own brain using this
system and medieval world to see if the
loris has put any road code in there
this is similar to how he was invaded by
four in season two and this corruption
has given him a lot of paranoia
after Stubbs beats down the security the
two have to leave but they now have more
information that will lead them to Maeve
Bernard is going to go looking for Liam
Dempsey to hopefully get a lead on
Dolores and Stubbs gets a new core
directive to protect Bernard I'm glad
this happened as I absolutely loved the
tuna team and I can't wait to see what
adventures they get up to in the future
the episode finishes with Mei rescuing
her own brain by reformatting a drone we
can see that in the room there are
several other pills and therefore it is
possible that these are some of the
hosts from the park that have been taken
in place they're actually believed that
the man in black will be in one of these
and that they will be to testing him for
fidelity through a lot of simulations
the drone almost makes its way out but
unfortunately it's shot down after an
almost videogame first-person-shooter
escape with slow-motion turned on Mable
wakens in a white dress in the real
world and she meets a rock played by
vincent cassell as we learn from last
week this is the man who is currently in
control of the machine that has
preordained a path for everyone on the
planet similar to how it created a
journey and narrative for everyone on
earth he wants to create one for Maeve
and that is to kill Dolores so Rach is a
futurist and he knows that a war is
coming that humanity are doomed to lose
the system that is creating a future for
the planet has hit a roadblock as it
cannot predict what Dolores will do and
they need her out of the picture
Maeve was once more back under the
control of the humans and we see that
she's been relegated to being their
slave so Rach would rather persuade her
instead of forcing her to do it and due
to the potential permanent paralysis
that could come from it I do believe she
will join his side we do have Bernard in
May both looking for the law
but whether they will actually kill her
now we don't know yet personally now
that they will but it will be
interesting to see how things progress
going forward unlike last week there's
no post credit scene but the promo does
look like there will be a lot in store
we pick up with Dolores in an ambulance
who's likely ended up there because
Caleb doesn't know that she's a machine
she escapes it and by the looks of it
kills the paramedics and it seems like
she wants to start a revolution we're
also getting a look at who Hale really
is and this is one of the deepest
mysteries in the show now though we
guessed it was Teddy last time
apparently closed captions showed that
it was Abernathy I haven't been able to
verify this myself but I did get a lot
of comments on it on the last video so
it looks like it is indeed true Hale is
looking after what also seems to be
Bernards child and it's likely that
she's been given this in order to ground
her it is possible that this was given
to control her by Dolores much in the
same way that Ford would control Bernard
we do know that the child has died
before so is possible that this same
scenario could happen in order to
manipulate him or her I don't know at
this point anyway I'm really enjoying
the series so far and this was another
mind-blowing episode that I absolutely
loved watching now obviously had loved
hear your thoughts on it and what you
took from the second entry comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the title sequence which is
gonna be linked at the end we go over
all of the hidden meanings in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below that was
the best ways table 8 with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace